Que dois-je faire, bien sûr, sous contrôle.
donc tu veux être pris
C'est ainsi que les médias grand public sont sous contrôle
si pris sous contrôle sur les réseaux sociaux
dans le montant que l'on veut prendre
toute dissidence sociale.
il n'y a pas de cul de Twitter donc
en l'écrivant
Bien sûr, c'est ainsi que les médias sociaux sourient.
En fait, dans l'esprit des gens
crée de la peur et des points d'interrogation
particulièrement jeune comme moi en ce moment
Je me demande s'il a des réserves sur le social
Ne pourrons-nous pas entendre librement les médias ?
vos avis sur les réseaux sociaux
un problème désormais à partager
comme s'il allait créer
s'abonner